welcome back have you been trying to
lose weight with diet and exercise but
are not seeing the results dr nash and
total transformation who is the sponsor
of the next segment can help look at
what she did here for dave
dr nash was my last shot at losing
weight i went from a 42 to a 32 and lost
66 pounds in six months wow dr nash
first off welcome to the show and we
just saw dave and actually jotted this
down because he said something he said
dr nash was my last shot at losing
weight and i think that is so key i
think so many people try diet and
exercise and all these different things
they don't get the results they come to
you and they do why is that
and they do but i'm like their last stop
on that road because they're so
frustrated they're doing everything
they're told to do to get the weight to
come off and the body's not responding
and it's because for more than 70
percent of people who are overweight or
obese it's damage that's driving the
weight problem not how much they eat or
move and that was certainly true with
dave and one of the things you talked
about before is fatty liver now would
dave have an issue with fatty liver and
why does fatty liver prevent someone
from losing weight so the problem is the
liver is the main organ that turns your
body fat into the fuel you burn so think
of fatty liver kind of like a clogged up
toilet jc if i've got a clogged up
toilet it can't do the conversion so
when people tell us to lose weight to
fix fatty liver it's absolutely not true
it is reversible but you have to do the
right thing when we did it to him the
weight just dropped off all around that
midsection
so how can someone tell if they have
fatty liver how do you discover this one
of the best things you can do at home to
determine if you have fatty liver is to
determine if you're in the obese
category that means a body mass index or
bmi over 30 and for men if you're bigger
than 40 inches around the tummy for dave
he came to me at a 42 and he left at a
32 so he reversed it but that's how
you're gonna tell take your waist
measurement and your bmi if those are
both positive it means you've got some
phase of fatty liver well can diet and
exercise be the simple cure to this no
because for a lot of times it's what
we're eating as well as how much we're
eating that's driving the problem so for
so many americans they're being told to
eat less and move more and it doesn't
convert the liver at all and so as a
result they don't burn very much body
fat the liver doesn't get turned around
they get frustrated and they give up
that's the cycle that we want to stop
now if someone feels like they have an
issue with fatty liver should they go
see a doctor first for a program or this
is something that you can help fix
well here's the frustrating part about
that jc if we have a fatty liver we go
to our doctor there is no drug or
medical treatment for it so they're not
going to be able to give you any answers
it is reversible but you have to know
specifically what to do to get it to
reverse and it's not
weight loss your weight has nothing to
do with it you have the answers dr nash
and every time you come to the show you
do bring a special what's the special we
have for us this week in order to do
that online evaluation with me and talk
to me it's normally 97 but when you see
me on las vegas now with jc of course
i'm going to bring you guys some kind of
way to talk to me at a much less price
so we've set aside a few spots available
about 10 where you can do it for 9.97 so
figure out your bmi measure your belly
and then make that appointment but do it
online because that's where you're going
to get the special offer
thank you to dr nash and total
transformation for sponsoring this
segment take advantage of her special
offer and visit her online at drnash.com
forward slash eval mercedes